do you see this kind of visualization
being useful for other things
in career and all those kinds of things
all 100
100 because
i just know with my own life my own my
own experiences like i
like my wife sometimes says to me she
says well where do you see yourself in
like you know
five years from now yeah and five years
ago
i had said to her you know i want to
have my own business i want to have
you know i i this is the amount of money
that i'm hoping i can make in a given
year like you have to have goals for
yourself like is this if you put out
there like okay i want to make a million
dollars in a year
that's a big number like like for me or
for the normal person like that's a
really big number you know what i mean
like it's not especially when you're not
making that much at the time it's a
super big number right so having those
goals for yourself like it it won't
happen and it's not possible unless you
dream
it's possible
and think it that it's possible and then
it doesn't magically happen and maybe it
doesn't happen in five years maybe
happens in ten but at least you're on
the path to getting there
you know what i mean and i said i wanna
own my own business i wanna control my
own destiny i want to be my own boss i
want to make my own decisions like these
are the things that i told her i wanted
to do and and now
i'm at that point
you know where you know i work for
myself i have my own company i have
partners obviously but like if i want to
pick up and go somewhere for a week i
just do i have to ask permission to do
it
right that that's what life freedom
right that's what i like yeah it's so
and all of it starts with a dream
in in the same with my dojo when i first
opened so i ran a dojo for a long time
and i only had 60 students always like
40 to 60 students had fluctuated
and i sit there and say why can't i get
more people in my door right so i hired
consultants to come in and look at my
business and say why right and
they came in and said well this place is
really intimidating like if i was coming
in off the street the first thing i see
is this big olympic champion on the wall
and i see this training that's going on
and these guys are flying through the
air and landing hard and as a white belt
you're telling me that's the class for
me like no way i'm not going to do that
so like i listened to these people i
said you're right
and you know the training was hour and a
half two hours long people can't handle
an hour and a half for two hours
training when they're first walking in
the door so i had to restructure all my
programming
i had to look at the way i was offering
my my curriculum at my school and i had
to make
levels for everybody right like
here's my four to six year old class
here's my six to 13 year old class
there's my all my beginner classes they
don't mix in with the advanced people
and like
you know and i had to learn how to
make it accessible for everybody instead
of just the the people that wanted to
train hard and
then the challenge was okay if you can
have a lot of people in your dojo
training
it's a recreational school you can't
produce champions at that same school
that's what i was told
so then i got all my black belts
together and i said listen this is my
vision this is what i want i want to
have a club that has over 200 judo only
athletes no jiu-jitsu no karate nothing
judo only
i want over 200 people
and in the inside of that dojo i want to
have olympic champions and i want to
have recreational like little kids five
and six years old older guys in their
70s training i don't care but i want the
spectrum of recreational and i want
olympic champions the only way to do
that is
to take your instructors and say you're
going to do this define the roles who's
going to be the recreational coach who's
going to be the competitive coach how do
we separate these programs and lo and
behold that was my vision that i shared
with all of them and that was back in
and by 2012
we've got olympic champion kayla
harrison we have over 200 people at the
school we have a successful thriving
business but it doesn't happen without
that vision
a plan
and believing that
it's possible believing that it's
possible
i don't know but i personally have uh
on top of that
almost like very specific visions of of
a future like uh um
i don't know what an because i don't
want to give actual examples
because for several reasons one of which
is just people will
as they often have they often will in
your life they'll just
laugh at it a little bit like that seems
silly
and i don't i'm very hesitant to share
certain things like that with people
because they'll
i mean um i'm with johnny ive
who's the lead designer in apple like
you want that dream that little flame to
not people will put that flame out too
easily even people that love you
so i have very specific kind of
visions like well maybe for travis it
would be like a specific opponent or
something like holy bishop like very
specific
very specific situation of what's going
to happen not just like i want to be
olympic champion but very specific like
almost silly situations yeah like the
dynamic between travis and ollie bishop
or something like maybe visualize that
for me that helps because it makes it
all real even more real it's not like
some big goal like a million dollars or
something like that which is also really
important to have because you can
measure it and so on but the
it's it's just like you belong in those
situations
just believing you belong right right
right in right there it's not that it
could be you yeah it could be you and
that for some reason that really helps
me the the little details sure like
visualizing
most of them are almost a little bit
funny
like the the focusing on the funniness
it's the
the mundaneness of it
uh helps me a lot and all the people
that have done great things they're just
human too
correct and i think a lot of people
overestimate
who others are
right and don't
and and sell themselves too short yeah
because at the end of the day everybody
started
like everybody else really i mean we did
you know we were all infants we couldn't
walk we couldn't talk we couldn't do
anything we learned along the way but
and i think that's the one thing that i
realized is that
and i
tell this to to my athletes but i also
tell it to my recreational students
nobody is better than you are nobody
unless you allow them to be
right if you really want something to
happen then like map the plan
believe in yourself decide and no full
out
you're going to fail a lot you're going
to get beat down you're going to have
losses you're going to have struggles
like i think that's the one thing with
social media today is that
everybody sees everybody succeed nobody
posts a picture when they're on the
ground in failure losing like nobody
nobody sees when you broke your arm and
you had to go through rehab you know
whatever it is like had your injuries
and you're on your couch watching tv and
you were suffering and you were like
everybody has really really dark bad
moments in their life and defeats and
losses and suffrage
and it's only at the end after they've
recovered from all of that they've
reclined up the mountain and they've
gone to the pinnacle that you see them
on social media with the metal
right but everybody else
like struggles and was human and
failed many many times and
you know
convincing yourself that you're capable
i think is the first start with
everything do you need people in your
life that
believe in you or should
most of it come from within yourself
i think most of it has to come in from
from it it certainly helps but it has to
come from you
first you have to be driven like other
people can help you
define where you want to go and help you
get there and encourage you and can
support you and you know whether it's
resource wise or with connections and
like they can help with that path but
that that first part has to come from
you it has to be your passion your
desire your it's your commitment to
yourself you're the one that's going to
ultimately make all the sacrifices to do
it so you ha it has to be your decision
not your parents not your spouse's
something that you're really motivated
to do
you